[Aplausos]
les voy a contar algo que probablemente
les parezca inverosímil pero que es
cierto yo estuve en un escenario en un
escenario como este antes de nacer tal
cual iba en el vientre de mi madre
mientras ella actuaba en obras teatrales
soy pues hijo de una actriz nieto
bisnietos tataranietos de actores y de
actrices eso por un lado por el otro soy
hijo de un hombre judío al que no conocí
un hombre al que apenas puede ver unos
cuantos minutos durante mi adolescencia
un hombre que no supo o no pudo estar
conmigo así es que la extraña ecuación
afectiva que me dio a luz es una suerte
de historia prohibida entre un hombre
judío y una mujer católica en el méxico
de los años 60
y el resultado el producto de esa
historia fue un niño un niño peculiar
solitario imaginativo valiente al que le
faltaban piezas de su rompecabezas
piezas que a los demás niños no les
faltaban un niño que se esforzaba por
entender por qué su cuento no cuadraba y
por qué no cuadraba el cuento porque por
un lado vivía una realidad cotidiana
llena de ficción con actores y actrices
fundamentalmente actrices mujeres que no
entendían dónde empezaba la vida real y
dónde terminaba el teatro así esos
desayunos de ese niño que soy que fui y
que sigo siendo yo no se podían
distinguir muy claramente de una
tragedia griega o de una obra de
federico garcía lorca y por el otro lado
en ese cuento el niño se tenía que
imaginar un mundo real judío el de su
padre y sus hermanos que vivían en la
misma ciudad
que él lo sabía en ese mismo momento un
mundo real pero ficticio verdadero pero
inalcanzable prohibido vedado
y la manera en la que ese niño intentó
hacer conciliar la historia en la que
intento hacer que el rompecabezas tomar
la forma en la que trató de explicarse
porque era como era que le pasaba que
había hecho que sucedieran esas cosas
pero sobre todo la manera en la que se
pudo enfrentar al siempre hostil mundo
de los niños fue saliendo a buscar las
piezas del rompecabezas y al no
encontrar las inventando las inventando
sus primeras ficciones oa lo mejor
inventándose a sí mismo como una ficción
así un día de buenas a primeras en la
escuela frente a sus compañeros
transformó a su padre ausente en un
soldado israelí que peleaba batallas
heróicamente en un desierto de medio
oriente
o yendo un poco más lejos otro día
sustrajo un equipo de una sinagoga y se
le empezó a poner en la cabeza
escondidas antes de entrar al salón de
clases cuando nadie lo veía para entrar
así frente a sus compañeros por obra y
gracia de la ficción ese niño se había
convertido en otra cosa había pasado de
ser un niño sin padre a transformarse en
un niño judío hijo de un héroe militar
acababa de descubrir la magia y el poder
de la ficción y empezó a caminar por ese
camino por ese sendero pronto empezó a
escribir historias en pequeños cuadernos
en donde animaba le daba vida a objetos
que lo rodeaban un timbre postal se
angustiaba porque se despegaba de una
carta una pluma no una pluma cualquiera
la pluma de beethoven se conmovía al ver
como los sentimientos de ese genio se
transformaban a través de ella en música
eso es lo que el niño hacía pero lo que
estaba haciendo ese niño ese yo era
realmente construir espejos en los que
se reflejaba el mismo
sus angustias sus miedos sus deseos sus
fantasías fue un poco más lejos cuando
apareció su primer ángel de la guarda mi
tía alicia la hermana de mi madre que un
día me regaló una máquina de escribir
para que me convirtiera verdaderamente
en un gran escritor rápidamente me puse
a trabajar sobre ella seguro de que iba
a escribir una obra maestra y un buen
día llamé a mi tía y le dije escrito un
cuento genial escucharlo se lo leí y no
pude creer su respuesta seria pero dulce
me dijo que lo que le estaba leyendo era
prácticamente palabra por palabra un
cuento famoso de los hermanos grimm un
plagio literalmente todavía recuerdo a
ese niño llorando desconsolado y negando
eso todavía hoy delante de ustedes juro
que creo que yo escribí ese cuento
acababa de descubrir que la ficción es
pública pero privada acababa de
descubrir el derecho de autor la
propiedad intelectual y no me hacía
ninguna gracia pero puedes superar ese
primer fracaso literario pude reponerme
saben cómo
empecé a descubrir que podía pilotear
unas naves de ficción increíbles unas
naves que se llaman ópera teatro
literatura
cine ballet y que con ellas podía
empezar a armar modelos a generar
modelos que me faltaban modelos
masculinos modelos de paternidad modelos
de amor al padre de fraternidad de amor
de pareja pero no sólo eso empecé a
generar mis códigos sociales políticos
emocionales fundamentalmente y además
atravesando toda mi adolescencia en esas
naves llegué a una isla una isla sobre
poblada de seres maravillosos de seres
que al mismo tiempo eran reales pero no
que se podían tocar pero no se podían
tocar que existían pero no existían y
que se llamaban personajes y dentro de
esos personajes descubrí que existe uno
que se llama tiempo que el tiempo es un
personaje el más caprichoso de todos que
iba para adelante para atrás que subía
que bajaba que a veces iba en sentidos
contrarios y ahí descubrí que el tiempo
es un invento humano muy equivocado y
que los relojes como ese que me está
amenazando
con una verdadera mentira eso es lo que
entendí y así caminando por ese sendero
insisto llegué por supuesto a mi primer
beso al momento en el que pude besar a
la chica de la adolescencia a la que
amaba donde frente a una ficción como
era previsible en un cine frente a una
película romántica cumplí ante esa
fantasía mi fantasía de tanto tiempo y
logré llegar a ese día maravilloso
eterno que no termina de terminar y así
de ficción en ficción llegue a mi primer
libro publicado tríptico tres actos en
una ópera donde como se pueden imaginar
lo que estaba haciendo era explorar la
diferencia o la dificultad para
diferenciar la vida real de la ficción
en ese caso de la ópera que es ha sido y
será una de las grandes pasiones de mi
vida pero realmente lo que estaba
haciendo era entender que escribir
ficción no es inventar historias es
escribirse a uno mismo corregirse
mejorarse convertirse en quien uno
quiere ser o dejar de ser quien uno ya
no quiere dejar de ser
seguí en ese terreno y pasaron 10 años
10 años es el periodo habitual que me
lleva a publicar un nuevo libro no sé si
es mucho o es poco pero es así es algo
que se cumple rigurosamente y llegó al
segundo libro que se titula no honrarás
a tu padre
una novela desde resonar bastante lógico
no después de ésta impúdica confesión
que les he hecho pensarán que es una
novela autobiográfica pues no no lo es
no es una autobiografía es un
autorretrato que no es lo mismo y saben
por qué porque lo que dice el libro son
puras mentiras una tras otra tras otra
90% del libro son mentiras y sin embargo
cuentan mi historia con una fidelidad
misteriosa ahí entendí que esto es la
literatura un mentir y mentir y mentir
para poder decir la verdad y que tenemos
muy sobrevalorada a veces la verdad y
muy injustamente su valor
a la mentira pasaron otros 10 años y
llegué a mi siguiente y más reciente
libro éxtasis una novela en siete
cápsulas que estaba haciendo con esa
novela estaba ahora mintiendo desde la
ciencia hablando de la química de las
emociones porque porque además de
estudiar piano estudia bioquímica si
está rara la combinación y no termino de
entender porque estudia bioquímica no lo
terminaba de entender si sabía que nunca
iba a ejercer esa carrera y saben cuando
lo entendí cuando vi la novela publicada
entendí que había estudiado bioquímica
para escribir la novela
que era como si la novela me hubiera
escrito a mí estudiando bioquímica para
poderla escribir como si la novela se
estuviera auto escribiendo a través de
mí como la famosa mano el dibujo de ayer
en el que una mano dibuja a una mano que
la dibuja dibujando la revirtiendo
destruyendo cancelando el tiempo esto
quiere decir que soy un escritor lento
perezoso ocasional no no es así todo el
tiempo estuve escribiendo todos ustedes
todos estamos escribiendo todo el tiempo
en el cine en el baño en el trabajo en
la mesa cuando estamos desayunando con
la familia cuando hacemos el amor ese es
un terreno muy fértil para la
imaginación y para la ficción aunque no
lo digamos todos todos somos unas
verdaderas máquinas de ficción
cotidianamente y la prueba más grande de
eso es el sueño es soñar cuando estamos
dormidos en nuestra situación más
vulnerable más indefensa tal vez en
nuestro estado
más puro estamos inventando ficciones en
ese momento en el que nuestro cerebro
desecha memorias temporales y consolida
memorias permanentes inventamos
historias wow realmente es increíble
me detengo un momento y me pregunto ante
ustedes de qué estoy hablando estoy
hablando realmente de ficciones de arte
saben de qué estoy hablando estoy
hablando del otro del otro con mayúscula
de los otros de todos esos que están
alrededor de nosotros y que nos
conforman y a los que nosotros también
hacemos todos esos otros que es lo que
la ficción nos permite tener entrar en
contacto con esos otros vivir con ellos
amar con ellos sufrir con ellos y
también morir con ellos finalmente este
entrar en contacto con los demás con los
otros es lo que llamamos empatía que es
la empatía la ciencia lo ha definido
dice que es un cóctel neuroquímico en el
que se dispara la serotonina para sentir
más amor por los demás más paz más
dulzura en el que baja la dopamina para
que sintamos menos comportamientos
agresivos en el que sube la oxitocina
para que sintamos confianza en los demás
sin embargo también hay otras
definiciones el arte la literatura
también define la empatía y ese estar
con el otro y quién mejor que octavio
paz- nuestro premio nobel de literatura
que lo dice con una frase maravillosa
que desde hace años no puedo olvidar en
su poema piedra de sol para que sea yo
he de ser otro salir de mi buscarme
entre los otros los otros que no son si
yo no existo los otros que me dan plena
existencia fin de la cita pero no sólo
son los escritores no sólo son los
artistas los que hacen ficción piensen
en la ciencia piensen en un newton en un
einstein en un hacking piensen en el
'big bang' en los agujeros negros en los
pliegues espacio-tiempo gravitatorios
einstein ya nos que es eso cuentos son
ficciones se estaban contando a sí mismo
un cuento porque no cuadraba tampoco su
rompecabezas y luego lo llenaron de
ciencia de matemáticas
y pudieron contarlo piensen por ejemplo
también en los grandes deportistas en
los deportistas de élite en mi
idolatrado messi en estos goles de
fantasía en esos pases y jugadas en
imaginables por supuesto que ese hombre
también escribe por supuesto que está
haciendo ficción como todos los grandes
deportistas como michael jordan al menos
una fracción de segundo antes de lograr
esas jugadas se las imaginan y luego las
trazan con su cuerpo
piensen en los movimientos sociales
piense en el martin luther king que dijo
martin luther king dijo tengo una teoría
tengo un concepto tengo un proyecto dijo
ihab dream tengo un sueño tengo una
ficción tengo un cuento y le pidió un
pueblo entero que le ayudara a contarlo
vivimos en un país terriblemente
violento y creo que eso puede cambiar
con la ficción
e infundiendo la buena ficción la buena
literatura el buen teatro la buena ópera
el buen cine porque hoy sabemos que
consumir esa buena ficción genera el
mismo cóctel de neuro químicos que nos
permite sentir empatía y también sabemos
científicamente demostrado que si
sentimos empatía por alguien no lo
podemos lastimar no lo podemos agredir
aquí está la ecuación a mayor buena
ficción mayor empatía ya mayor empatía
menores comportamientos delictivos no
podemos hacer nada ni lo más cotidiano
ni lo más ordinario ni lo más heroico si
no nos lo imaginamos antes
finalmente quiero pedirles algunos
favores quiero pedirles que hagan algo
quiero pedirles que crean en la ficción
porque siempre les va a decir algo de
ustedes quiero que estimulen que
encaucen que alienten a los jóvenes a
sus hermanos a sus hijos a ustedes
mismos a sus padres a consumir buena
ficción siempre les va a enseñar quiénes
son vivan ficción nadan en la ficción
háganle el amor a la ficción sud en
ficción respiren ficción va a ser su
mejor maestra porque siempre siempre les
va a enseñar algo sin proponer enseñar
se los quieren cambiar quieren ser
mejores quieren hacer un gran proyecto
una gran obra un gran producto una gran
empresa
primero cuenten se da imagínense la
y después escriban la con su vida
y recuerden estas palabras recuerden las
muy bien todas las historias que se han
escrito se escriben y se escribirán han
empezado empiezan y empezarán siempre
siempre con las mismas palabras érase
una vez yo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]